[Music]
well the fun group welcome to detention
Spencer definite fridge Martha you're
all here for a reason you should be
thinking about who you are and who you
want to be you'll have plenty of time to
figure that out while you're cleaning
out the basement are you gonna help
are you too pretty I'm too pretty yo
what's this I've gained for those who
seek to find a way to leave their world
behind Jumanji pick a character and
you're that person in the game which one
real quick I don't think it matters how
much loose Finbarr don't look at badass
I'll be the curvy genius dr. smolder
brave stuff guess I'm Ruby roundhouse
guys where's the rest of me my god
rich damn fridge who are you wearing
half a shirt and short shorts in the
jungle think we got sucked into Jumanji
we become the avatars we chose so that
means Bethany don't look at it I'm a
middle-aged man I don't have my claritin
and all I see around here is Paul I
don't have to talk to my buddy
damn it as a man right there don't cry
don't cry don't cry it's gonna be okay
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
it was so intense
I like Kent even with this place step in
here
[Music]
they will what no game machine muscle
like you get in there saver but I'm not
gonna get in there you get in there yeah
I got a backpack don't get water with a
backpack everybody knows that
[Music]